on my last night I checked out one of
Haiti's top roots music fans
grammy-nominated Bookman experienced and
as you can imagine I blended in
seamlessly
[Music]
it was the perfect end to an
unforgettable trip during my brief visit
I was blown away by the warmth
generosity independence passion and
humor of the Haitian people the rest of
the world needs to catch up to what the
Haitian people already know that they
have all it takes to thrive as a nation
you are an extraordinary people
you're a beautiful people and I think
great things are coming your way
viz I'm in a book stall in Haiti and I
just love the randomness of this is my
friend Eric he's been helping us out on
this trip he's been amazing we also
found out that he is the Haitian Rock
give it to him liked him so much more
than the Haitian Vin Diesel you're great
and fantastic one more time yeah hey
check it out remember that tap tap
painting I showed you that earlier today
Tony is the guy that made it this is
going on a tap tap crazy thank you you
welcome that looks
I'm here at école navale at Sobrante I'm
gonna learn some creole today should
should go well I'm in Haiti and just now
getting the news about the government
shutdown in the United States thank God
I'm in Haiti where the government
actually works
you